welcome to this new m7 b5 yep that yeah
I played him before just once but I did
ok so the modern benoni I wanted to try
a different line now I have played a
form ok not a big deal I can play what I
usually do wanted to try and early
Bishop a four-line am a student recently
pointed this line out to me and I really
liked it just a moment down I'd be fine
about something is this on ok if I think
about those things I will lose on time
ok beef b5 I have a phone and it is very
slow what is doing so why not let's just
do this you can quite often actually
allow b5 it's not a completely mandatory
thing to to play a form almost but not
not completely so night III nights if
one looks quite ok shift on f4 is a bit
strange but shouldn't be a problem i
hope i mean 95 as a move them
not if nobody's going there
ip6 a megan playing at ft seven maybe
push up on a form i don't like that I
don't want to play Knight c4 and treat
some traits too many pieces him that
definitely helps them
so it gives me the a file okay
still this is not very harmonious I want
H to for this bishop so somehow maybe I
can regroup this yeah okay night f5 what
is this is completely ridiculous not
completely but almost yes night is a
queen of six at the end you will attack
be too so it's not happening g5 is not a
threat though night if five however
might be Queen f6 is apostles
I didn't like my position here Heitkamp
like we have six even here only okay
didn't do that preventing pawn to c4
Knight g4 maybe but you can't eat with
the bishop ok but just anticipating ok
3m right everyone f 1 d 2 or something
like that
need to get my pieces untangled yeah I
really have a weird piece coordination
threating I'm threatening
tongue-twisting unthreatening f4 so what
I threatened but ok I can go all night
at five now I don't know if it is a good
idea but I get the 924 and I think I'm
doing that let's do that my position
really lacks ideas and T I really have
an idea at least put this night only
form and I threatening f6 of course so
you cannot take on d5 maybe I can get
the Bishop to c4 and then night if I it
could be quite quite interesting so
let's come here on 94 immediately
nightie for immediate lame yeah I can do
that up so I can do that ok can take on
d5 ok let's do that first
d 5 is important it's not just a pawn
the night from d5 was threatening to go
to e3 so I'm not trying to keep this
night on b6 at bay than anything else ok
I want even to go here
I cannot grow k14 time warning my BF for
my night is unprotected down I don't
know I don't know but I have to have to
move some move here Queen edge five is
at least a threat now 56 plan he
blundered black resigns Jim tens
position probably a bad position now i
really miss played that in more than one
way Jeb probably I should play for but I
thought it was interesting to allow this
for once sometimes you can do that but
you played before even voluntarily so
this actually should be quite good but I
told I didn't really get something going
my nights up a bit iffy they are III and
g3 yeah probably is ok computer likes
white quite a bit but I'm not sure about
this age 3 doesn't want to do that and
this one 494 yeah maybe I have to do
that I didn't want to trade this p6
sorry I was the wrong square that b6
night because normally in the be known
you don't want to trade so many pieces
as black as a bit cramped but maybe I
have to do this simply because my pieces
are so weird and it serves to coordinate
them now here I'm worse definitely
yeah i'm just trying to somehow
coordinate my pieces and maybe a that
was was quite okay and i defy very
debatable decision but i wanted some
concrete idea and yeah this is good for
black now Bishop c4 and this is also
good young yeah I have um chances on the
Kings side a bit but it's not enough to
compensate for the a file and the
protected passed pawn before here and
then fyd now he has to an idea for his
winning for black okay yeah I didn't see
that one and he's threatening made them
instead he took and now it gets gets
more interesting still like g6 was good
and this blended everything so that was
lucky he really played well in that bin
only and I had huge huge problems okay
well thanks for watching